TREY: NOW INTO THE SECOND WEEK
OF WAR IN EUROPE ACTUALLY THE
SECOND WEEK OF WATCHING WAR IN
EUROPE FROM AFAR.
LIKE A PERSON SAFELY LOOKING
DOWN FROM A HIGH RISE
APARTMENT ON TO A CITY STREET
FAR BELOW YOU CAN SEE THE
VICTIM BEING ATTACKED YOU
OFFERED TO CALL THE POLICE AND
AFTER A WORD OF ENCOURAGEMENT
FOR SAFETY AND MAYBE EVEN
ALERT OTHERS TO THE INJUSTICE
YOU ARE OBSERVING THE EVIL DO
EVERYTHING EXCEPT THEY
ACTUALLY NEEDED TO DO WITCHES
HELP.
UKRAINE HAS ASKED FOR HELP.
THEY ASK OUR SENATORS OVER THE
WEEKEND FOR HELP FOR NO-FLY
ZONE AND MORE SANCTIONS AND
ANYTHING TO STOP THE MASSACRE.
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN INSPIRED
BY THE COURAGE OF THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE WITH THEIR
RESOLVE INGENUITY AND
WILLINGNESS TO FIGHT IN THE
FACE OF OVERWHELMING EYES AND
THEY HAVE AN OUTRAGE THE
KILLING OF WOMEN AND CHILDREN
IMAGES OF FAMILIES SEPARATED
FROM FAMILIES PERHAPS FOREVER
IN THE EFFORT TO SIMPLY
SURVIVE.
WE ARE SIMPLY OUTRAGE THE
MULTIPLE ATTEMPTS TO
ASSASSINATE PRESIDENT
ZELENSKY, THE RECKLESSNESS OF
RUSSIA AND A RUSSIA'S NUCLEAR
DISASTER.
AMERICA IS INSPIRED AND
OUTRAGED NOT ENOUGH TO
ACTUALLY JOIN THE FIGHT.
WE ARE TOLD THERE IS A
CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATION TO
DEFEND COUNTRIES LIKE POLAND
AND ESTONIA AND LITHUANIA AND
A CONTRACT TO DEFEND CONTRACTS
ARE WHAT WE SIGNED TO REPAY
BANK LOANS AND GET CELL PHONE
SERVICE.
MORALITY SHOULD NOT REQUIRE A
CONTRACT.
MOST OF OUR OBLIGATIONS IN
LIFE ARE NOT CONTRACTUAL.
THEY ARE DEEPER THAN THAT.
WE DON'T NEED A CONTRACT FOR A
VICTIM FROM A BULLY THERE'S NO
CONTRACTOR WE SEE A CHILD
BEING ATTACKED OR AN ELDERLY
PERSON BEING ASSAULTED OR A
SINGLE PERSON AMBUSHED.
WE DON'T NEED A CONTRACT WE
JUST NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHO
OUR NEIGHBORS REALLY ARE WE
ARE TOLD POLAND IS WORTH
DEFENDING AND ROMANIA AND
SLOVAKIA THOSE OUR NEIGHBORS
BECAUSE WE SIGNED A CONTRACT
ALL THAT SEPARATES THOSE WE
WILL DEFEND FROM THOSE WE WILL
NOT DEFEND IS A SINGLE STEP A
SINGLE STEP ON A MAP EACH OF
THOSE HAS A BORDER WITH
UKRAINE SO MORAL OUTRAGE THE
DUTY TO DEFEND IS DEPENDENT
UPON A FAINT BOUNDARY LINE.
THE GATES OF FIRE THE 2000
-YEAR-OLD STORY ABOUT A SMALL
GROUP OF GREEK SOLDIERS WHO
WENT TO FIGHT A BATTLE THEY
COULD NOT WIN AGAINST AN ENEMY
THEY COULD NOT DEFEAT THEY
LEFT HOME TO ROOSEVELT -┘- LOSE
THE BATTLE IN HOPES IN THE
PROCESS THEY COULD INSPIRE
OTHERS TO TAKE UP ARMS AND
WHEN THE WAR BUT THERE WAS
SOME INSPIRED OTHERS TO WIN
THE WAR THAT WE BENEFIT FROM
2500 YEARS LATER DOING THE
RIGHT THING DOES NOT REQUIRE A
TREATY IT DOES NOT DEPEND UPON
A CONTRACT IT UPON DEPENDS
UPON THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE
AND THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF AND
TO WAGE WAR AND PERHAPS IT'S
TIME TO DEBATE WHAT WE
OURSELVES AND OTHERS TO
REALITY UKRAINIAN PEOPLE
SOMETHING MORE THAN WHAT WE
PROVIDED?
WE OURSELVES SOMETHING MORE
THAN OFFERING GOOD WISHES AND
HOPES FOR SAFE PASSAGE SO
INNOCENTS CAN ESCAPE THEIR
HOMELAND WITH THE GREATEST -┘-
WITH THE GREATEST COUNTRY
COULD OFFER?
IS IT TIME FOR THAT PEOPLE'S
HOUSE TO DEBATE WHAT IS ON THE
PEOPLE'S MINDS WHETHER WAR CAN
OR SHOULD BE DONE FOR A
COUNTRY INVADED, RAPED AND
KILLED BY A BULLY?
THERE IS A MARKER WITH THE
PERSIANS AND A MARKER SAYS GO
TELL THEM THE SINGLE SENATE
SERVE TO REMIND THE WORLD THEY
CARED ENOUGH TO ACTUALLY
SACRIFICE THEY DID NOT
CALCULATE THE ODDS OF WINNING
THE BATTLE THAT THE COST OF
LOSING THE LARGER WAR SO WHAT
WILL BE WRITTEN ABOUT US
DURING THAT TIME A BULLY
RAVISHED A NEIGHBORING COUNTRY
THAT WE RELIED UPON A
CONTRACT?
AND GOOD WISHES THAT WE SEES
THE YACHTS THAT UKRAINE WAS
NOT HER NEIGHBOR BETTER
NEIGHBORS NEIGHBOR AND ARE WE
OKAY WITH THAT?
ECHOING TO THE HALLS OF
HISTORY.
>> JOINING US NOW FORMER
SECRETARY OF DHS AND FORMER
TOP LAWYER DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE MR. SECRETARY WHAT IS
YOUR TAKE ON WHERE WE
CURRENTLY ARE IN THIS WAR AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S REAL
MOTIVES?
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
YOU CAN APPRECIATE WHAT I'M
ABOUT TO SAY BECAUSE YOU ARE A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS AND THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
I NO LONGER HAVE ACCESS TO
INTELLIGENCE REPORTS.
I'M NO LONGER A MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
SITTING IN THE SITUATION ROOM
WRESTLING WITH THE CHOICES AND
MISTAKES SO WHAT I SAY HAS TO
BE ACCEPTED WITHOUT
LIMITATION.
EIGHT DAYS AGO I SAID PUBLICLY
THAT THIS THING WOULD GET A
LOT WORSE BEFORE IT GOT BETTER
AND AS AMERICANS SAW THE
IMAGES OF CARNAGE IN THE
STREETS OF UKRAINE INNOCENT
MEN AND WOMEN AND CHILDREN
DYING AS A RESULT OF THE WAR
CRIMES, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WILL FACE
DOMESTIC AND INTERNATIONAL
PRESSURE TO DO MORE THAN WE
ARE DOING RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE RAPIDLY REACHING THEM
MOMENTS OF TRUTH WHEN WE MUST
DECIDE AS THE LEADER OF THE
FREE WORLD, WHETHER WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO BECOME MORE
DIRECTLY INVOLVED OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN UKRAINE.
BEFORE WE TAKE A STEP THAT'S A
HUGE STEP THAT WE HAVE NOT
SEEN IN GENERATIONS WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER A COUPLE OF THINGS.
ONE, IT'S MUCH EASIER TO
BECOME INVOLVED IN AN ARMED
CONFLICT AND TO EXTRICATE IF
WE PUT AMERICA IN HARM'S WAY
THEN WE MUST HAVE A CLEAR
MILITARY OBJECTIVE TO DO SO
AND IF WE FIND YOURSELVES IN A
CONFLICT WITH UKRAINE WE WILL
FIND OURSELVES IN DIRECT
CONFLICT WITH RUSSIA WE
MANAGED TO AVOID CONFLICT ALL
THROUGH THE COLD WAR DURING
THE CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS IN
1962.
THIS IS A MOMENT WE NEED TO
THINK VERY CAREFULLY ABOUT
NEXT STEPS.
I THINK IT WILL BE INEVITABLE
WE HAVE TO DO MORE.
I BELIEVE THAT PUTIN IS
DETACHED FROM REALITY.
HE HAS BEEN PRESIDENT OF
RUSSIA FAR TOO LONG.
HE'S NOT LISTENING TO HIS
CABINET ANYMORE AND HAS A
DETACHED SENSE OF REALITY.
HE PROBABLY BELIEVED HE WOULD
BE GREETED AS A LIBERATOR ON
THE STREETS OF UKRAINE.
SO WE NEED TO THINK CAREFULLY
ABOUT NEXT STEPS.
THEY HAVE MORE DIRECT
INVOLVEMENT IS MORE INEVITABLE.
MORE ARMS AND MORE SANCTIONS
BUT LESS BE CAUTIOUS IT IS A
PERILOUS MOMENT.
>> MANIFESTING ITSELF
DIFFERENT WAYS INCLUDING
CYBERATTACKS.
IS OUR COUNTRY PREPARED FOR A
CYBERATTACK?
AND THOSE THAT WE RELY UPON.
>> AS YOU KNOW MOST CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THIS COUNTRY
IS IN PRIVATE HANDS.
I BELIEVE WE NEED TO BE ON
HIGH ALERT RIGHT NOW.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY TO THE CYBERSECURITY
INFRASTRUCTURE AGENCY HAS PUT
OUT USEFUL GUIDANCE ON WHAT
THOSE IN CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE DEFENSE
INDUSTRIAL BASE NEED TO DO TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES AGAINST
CYBERATTACKS FROM RUSSIA.
WE HAVE SEEN CYBERATTACKS FROM
A RUSSIAN PLATFORM THE SOLAR
WIND ATTACK FOR EXAMPLE SO WE
HAVE A HUGE CAPABILITY AND NOT
RIGHT NOW IN MY JUDGMENT NEEDS
TO BE ON HIGH ALERT THE MORE
WE BECOME INVOLVED THE MORE IT
IS INEVITABLE THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT OR THE RUSSIAN
PLATFORM WILL DIRECT SOME FORM
OF CYBERATTACK AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES.
TREY: FORMER TOP LAWYE